欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 第十六章 我们来讲一下关于新店铺和老店铺的运营实战方法
通过这个方法能够让我们在尽量正确的方向上用对的运营方法来实现寻盘的稳步增长
那么很多人在接手新店铺或者是在接手老店铺的时候
不知道如何去运营 就会导致它在整体的思路上混乱 方法的选择上不合理
就会导致它在整个店铺的运营中没有节奏感 也没有清晰的一个方向跟具体的一个思路
每天就会导致很忙很累 但是具体的效果没有呈现出来
那么新店铺我们通常来讲是什么类型的店铺才算是新店铺呢
比如说你在六个月以内的店铺基本都算是新店铺
那么老店铺可能会是在一年的那些店铺以上
也有一些十几年了 但是一直没有人去打理 这些店铺的话 也是按照这种新店铺的思路去做的
这一章节非常的重要 对于你去操作新店铺还是老店铺都是有非常好的一个思路跟方法去运作的
那么接下来我们来讲第一小节就是关于新店铺发展的三个阶段
如果你是自己从零开始去做一个新店铺的时候 那么可以参考这个思路跟方法
另外一个就是你接手新店铺的时候也适合用 比如说你接手了一个刚起步三到一年内的店铺都可以 或者是六个月以内的店铺都是可以的
都是可以用这个方法跟思路的 那么我们运营的终极目的是什么呢
肯定是想让我们的店铺高质量寻盘量达到行业的优秀 是吧
然后完成交易额 也就是我们的业绩目标 那么接下来我们来看一下
这个新店铺的具体的操作是怎么样的 第一个阶段 我们肯定是优先考虑提升整体的寻盘量
第二个阶段就是去提升寻盘的质量 因为寻盘的质量才能够保证我们能够成交更容易
第三个就是寻盘的数量与质量和订单的一个均衡的发展
那么接下来我们来一个个进行详细的分析
第一个就是在寻盘数量方面 开始的时候店铺是不是没有什么数据
我们肯定是通过寻盘来提升整个店铺的一个权重
那么这个时候我们追求的肯定是寻盘量优先
但是呢我们要注意千万不要为了寻盘采用低价引流
因为这些低价引流的方式虽然说寻盘量起来了
但是你的很多的寻盘的目标国家都不是你想要的
那么不是你想要的话就会导致整个店铺的一个标签非常的混乱
那么标签混乱了之后下一个阶段你就要花非常多的时间和精力和金钱去把这个店铺的标签扭转
如果你扭转不过来
那么你这个店铺就会导致长期处于低质量的一个寻盘的状态
这样就非常非常影响你最后面的一个订单转化了
所以这个板块一定要重视
第二个阶段你寻盘量起来了
那么这个时候可能需要提升你的寻盘的质量了
因为很多寻盘的质量差导致成交不了
这个时候我们就要去追求寻盘的质量
那么在这个过程中很有可能就是你的寻盘的数量是会有所下降的
因为你筛选掉了很多非目标国家的寻盘
也就是说你这些寻盘被你筛选掉了
那么剩下的寻盘就是你比较有质量的寻盘
比如说要买家的寻盘
以及目标国家的寻盘
这些寻盘在逐渐的增长
那么就说明你这个阶段还是做的不错的
同时呢你这个阶段一定要去重视提升订单的转化率
因为你的这个阶段已经是在转向寻盘质量
所以说你质量起来了
那么你的一个订单量肯定是要有一定的保障
如果你连订单都没有
大多数就还在表示你的寻盘的质量还是不太行
不太行
因为你来的目标买家不是你想要的
所以才会导致你的寻盘转化不了成为订单
当然这个阶段也有可能是业务的问题
因为有些寻盘质量很好
寻盘量也还不错
但是有些新手的业务的话
那么他就不一定能够承接得住这些客户
所以这个时候也需要和业务共同去复盘一下
看看到底是运营层面的问题
还是说业务技能方面的问题
第三个阶段就是寻盘量与质量订单的均衡
那么在这个阶段我们寻盘的质量是有所提升了
提升了之后我们还要继续干嘛呢
就继续去提升寻盘量
因为质量有了
我们就想办法去提升有质量的寻盘的数量
时刻关注这些寻盘的质量和评估
如果你在操作的过程中
发现寻盘的质量又有所下降了
那么你就要开始去调整了
因为你不能为了追求这个数量的急剧增长
然后寻盘的质量回到了第一个阶段
那么这样的话也是不合理的
所以说一定要时刻的评估寻盘的质量
第三个就是要与业务持续的合作
提升订单的转化
也就是平时我们知道的哪些产品效果非常好
而且发来的寻盘质量非常高
那么针对这些产品我们一定要告诉业务积极的去用信保订单去绑定
同时呢我们要向业务获取一些当下客户需求的一些趋势
比如说现在客户对哪个品类哪种类型的产品更喜欢
那么这种问题最好的就是能跟业务沟通一下
看看能不能给你提供一些信息
这样就有利于你在后期在操作店铺的时候更加有侧重点
所以我们整体上来说还是要跟业务共同合作
一起去打造这个店铺的
单独靠运营的话
那么这个效果就没那么明显
那么以上就是关于新店铺发展的三个阶段
大概要三到六个月
如果你按照这个阶段去发展的话
基本是每个阶段都需要两个月
因为这是国际上是批发类的平台
它不可能马上这么快速的见效
除非你的产品很好
以及你的资源很多
不然的话你都需要时间去积累
所以我们在做新店铺的时候
一定要先构思你要怎么样去做这个店铺
你的整体的流程是怎么样的
时间节点是怎么样的
那么有了这个时间轴
你所要去做的事情就非常明确
以及你想要看到的效果
在哪个阶段会有什么样的结果
你都有一个清晰的一个预估
这样你去做事情就比较有条理
而且你能够非常的知道
你每周每个月要做什么
这样就不至于你浪费很多的时间
就能够在尽可能短的时间内
把这个店铺做起来
这个就是关于新店铺
或者是接受新店铺时候
所用的一些思路跟方法
希望这些思路跟方法
能够帮助你真正的
把一个新店铺快速做起来
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见